لم يتمتع نحو 400 الف التلميذ من تلاميذ
التعليم الاساسي بالعوده المدرسيه في عدد
من المحافظات التونسيه الى تاريخ اليوم
رغم مروري ما يقارب الشهرين على التحاق
زملائهم بفصول الدراسه
[موسيقى]
ازمه غير مسبوقه اندلعت بعد اندلعت نقابه
التعليم الاساسي المدرسين النواب الى عدم
الالتحاق بمراكز عملهم في المدارس الى حين
تسويه وضعهم المهني من قبل وزاره التربيه
والغاء عقود التشغيل الهشام وبسبب اقفل
باب الانتدابات كانت الوزاره
في المدرسين الجدد في المرحله الابتدائيه
مع عقود تشغيل هشه تعتمدها منذ سنوات لسد
حاجه القطاع من المدرسين
تتعارض العقود التي منحتها الوزاره مع
النظام الاساسي للمهنه وتمنح المعلمين
النواب تقريبا نصف الراتبي الذي يحدث به
زملائهم المنتدبون وفقا لقوانين العمل في
القطاع الحكومي
[موسيقى]
لم تنجح جلساته التفاوض بين وزاره التربيه
ونقابه التعليم الاساسي في الوصول الى حل
النقابه تتمسك بالتسويه التامه والوزاره
تتوعد بالتسعيد خاصه ان المهله التي
منحتها للمدرسين للالتحاق بمراكز العمل قد
انتهت
يقف الظرف الاقتصادي هو عائقا امام
الانتدابات في القطاع الحكومي وترفض
النقابات واستغلال منظورها والانتقال من
حقوقهم في حين يقبعو الاف التلاميذ في
منازلهم يترصدهم شبح الجهل في بلد طالما
رهنا على التعليم وعلى المصعد الاجتماعي
الى صباح العربيه احلام العبدلي تونس